what's the real story behind aunt viv
being replaced on the fresh prince which
cast member on frasier was the biggest
prima donna
behind all the smiles and life lessons
tv families often have as much drama as
real families
it wasn't all lovely ladies with golden
curls on the set of the brady bunch
especially when maureen mccormick and
eve plum were shooting together as
sisters marsha and jan respectively well
all i hear all day long at school is how
great marsha is at this or how wonderful
marsha did that marsha marsha marsha
as mccormick revealed in her 2009 memoir
here's the story plum resented her for
quote getting too much attention and it
only became worse as the kids grew up
susan olsen who played youngest brady's
sister cindy told fox news in 2009 that
mccormick and plum were eventually no
longer on speaking terms to the point
that whenever we get together for any
project there will only be one or the
other as olsen further explained eve got
tired of maureen gaining attention for
herself by regurgitating the tiresome
and false insinuations that they had a
lesbian affair fortunately like most
brady stories this one ultimately has a
happy ending as the on-screen sisters
had a chance to settle their squabble in
the hgtv miniseries a very brady
renovation which premiered in 2019 as
plum admitted to e it had been a really
long time since we had all been together
and it's really cool to see who people
are today and what they're doing it's
awesome it's so nice to reconnect with
people that you care about
who can forget the public spectacle that
was charlie sheen's exit from two and a
half men it should come as no surprise
that his fire burned a few bridges along
the way
the exact timeline of his departure from
the show is unclear but it undeniably
reached ahead when he called creator
chuck laurie a clown and a turd while
calling into alex jones's radio show
shortly afterwards sheen was fired from
the sitcom and the punches didn't stop
there after his firing sheen went on to
tell e news that his on-screen brother
john cryer was quote a turn coat a
traitor and a troll crier apparently
hadn't been outspoken enough in favor of
sheen after his firing and sheen also
claimed that he hadn't reached out to
him although crier claimed otherwise but
it seems that there are no hard feelings
too tough to forgive among tv families
as laurie later told entertainment
tonight that he didn't feel like he and
sheen were ever in a feud
i felt like he was my friend
i really loved the guy
crier meanwhile had more mixed feelings
about his time with sheen as he put it
in his memoir so that happened to some
sheen was a rebel a truth-teller willing
to poke his masters in the eye of course
charlie wasn't those things he was
simply lashing out at the people who
told him the party was over
the wb series charmed was anything but
at least not behind the scenes if
anything this late 90s early 2000s drama
about three magical sisters was rather
cursed shannon doherty and alyssa milano
played two of the sisters and they grew
to have a real-life beef so big that it
led to doherty's departure from the show
as milano recounted to e news in 2020
there were times when i'd come in and
say good morning shannon and she didn't
say anything to me and there were times
when she'd come in and say good morning
alyssa and i wouldn't say anything to
her
for doherty the routine silent
treatments weren't worth the paycheck as
she told entertainment tonight in 2001
i'm 30 years old and i don't have time
for drama in my life anymore with any
family infighting time passes people
grow there are regrets and hopefully
there are amends as milano later
admitted to entertainment tonight in
2021 i can take responsibility for a lot
of our attention
likewise doherty is letting bygones be
bygones as she put it on a 2015
appearance on sway in the morning are
there times that were rough yeah i mean
i think that when you work that closely
together there's always going to be
times that are rough sometimes you don't
always get along with the person
24 7 that you work with
while steve urkel technically had no
blood relation to the winslow family on
family matters he was at their house so
often that he deserves an honorary spot
at the table and the irate responses to
him from the winslow's on the show may
not have been too far from what was
going on behind the scenes on a 2021
episode of tv one's uncensored urkel
actor jaleel white rehashed some of the
early tension between himself and the
older actors on the show
as he put it i was not welcome to the
cast at all they know what it was i
didn't think anything of it being cast
to be on family matters because it was
supposed to only be a guest spot one and
done
as the story goes the other actors
bristled when the network shifted much
of the show's focus over to urkel as
reported by entertainment weekly there
was one particularly notable occasion
that also involved reginald valjohnson
and joe marie payton who played the
winslow parents white had to put on a
dress and two older actors pressured him
against wearing it as white recalled
they were very sensitive to putting
black men in dresses but over time the
familiarity among the cast improved
according to white phil johnson and
peyton do deserve credit at times for
having helped foster a more harmonious
environment
and we did become very much a family
isn't that the best any family real or
fictitious can help for
on the fresh prince of bel air aunt
vivian may have had the run of the
mansion but behind the scenes well smith
was definitely the top dog viewers may
recall the jarring recasting of aunt viv
originally played by janet hubert who
was replaced by daphne maxwell reed in
the fourth season and it wasn't exactly
a smooth transition for the rest of the
cast in a 2020 interview on wabc's here
and now hubert discussed her departure
from fresh prince she explained that she
wasn't fired but rather that she
rejected her contract renewal in the
hopes that the network would return with
a better offer instead they replaced her
though she wasn't surprised in her eyes
the production team seemed to have it
out for her as she put it they told me i
had to go into my dressing room in
between takes because i wasn't laughing
at will's jokes she even went so far as
to claim
the cast was offered money to take me
down hubert had a chance to confront
smith on a fresh prince reunion that
aired on hbo max in 2020. she didn't
hold back i've been banished
and they said it was you who
who banished me
he then offered an apology he reflected
further on the experience during the red
table talk interview as he admitted that
he was shaking during their conversation
that's not
who i want to be
and it's not
how i want to make people feel
hopefully smith makes the most of this
second chance
the jackson brothers on the nbc sitcom
were known for their bickering just like
any siblings who ultimately loved each
other but behind the scenes it was a
little more violent as todd bridges
reportedly slapped gary coleman although
coleman reportedly cast the first palm
bridges who played older brother willis
recounted the story of this backstage
fight in his 2010 autobiography killing
willis bridges felt that coleman was
getting too egotistical as his character
arnold was gaining popularity among the
fans according to bridges coleman would
always have an obnoxious comeback to
everything that was said around the set
on one occasion when he couldn't come up
with a comeback he slapped bridges who
then slapped him back unlike some of the
feuds on this list this one sadly does
not have the chance for a reconciliation
each of the three young leads bridges
coleman and dana plato struggled with
their fame after the show's conclusion
plato died of an overdose in 1999 while
coleman passed away in 2010 after
enduring financial struggles that led to
him declaring bankruptcy bridges who
dealt with his own drug addiction is now
the only surviving member of the
original main cast he's doing better
though as he put it during a 2016
appearance on the dr oz show i love life
now life is the best thing in the world
it's hard to forget roseanne barr's
explosive exit from the revival of her
eponymous abc sitcom in 2018 but just in
case you forgot here's a quick refresher
barr tweeted about former obama
administration advisor valerie jarrett
in which she linked her to the muslim
brotherhood and planet of the apes she
was then subsequently fired by abc for
the remark the rest of the cast narrowly
avoided a complete cancellation when
roseanne was rebranded as the spin-off
series the connors
in response to barr's tweet sarah
gilbert who plays roseanne's daughter
darlene tweeted in response
roseanne's recent comments about valerie
jarrett and so much more are abhorrent
and do not reflect the beliefs of our
cast and crew or anyone associated with
our show i am disappointed in her
actions to say the least
barr responded in turn as she claimed
that gilbert quote destroyed the show
and my life with that tweet despite this
rocky episode the connors has gone on to
flourish on abc and ultimately it would
seem that just like in real life some
family disputes are irreconcilable
for the most part the cast of frasier
appears to have been entirely amicable
with each other the human cast that is
as for family pup eddie he was actually
portrayed by two different canine actors
he was originally played by a jack
russell terrier named moose but he came
to share the role with his son enzo as
he got older often enough family and
business just don't mix and that was
certainly true on the set of frasier in
an interview on the show animal
magnetism enzo's trainer mathilde
ducanni revealed musa nanzo's
relationship is so bad that they can't
even be in the same room together
moose may be more to blame as decanny
explained that before he was an actor
his owners gave him up he had been
nothing else but a terror
the interviewers then connected the
bristling relationship between moose and
enzo to the equally difficult one
between human father and son duo frazier
and martin crane sadly enzo and moose
have both since passed now that their
on-set days are over hopefully they've
reconciled in doggy heaven
it's easy to over romanticize an iconic
classic sitcom like the andy griffith
show and certainly griffith himself
surely wanted audiences to have that
feeling as he put it in a 1996 today
show interview
it was of a time gone by but despite the
simple times in front of the camera
there was drama behind the scenes for
the most part the set of mayberry seems
to have been as blissful as the show
made it seem but one bit of trouble in
paradise stemmed from the difficult
relationship between griffith and his
cast mate frances bavier who played aunt
b
ron howard who played andy's son opie
discussed his memories of making the
show during an interview with the
television academy as he put it i don't
think she felt a part of what these boys
were up to in their shenanigans
while the cast has managed to keep
relatively tight lift about any
unpleasant feelings griffith did reveal
some details about his relationship with
bavier during an interview with ralph
emery on the show on the record
as he recalled she wasn't always in real
great shape emotionally but toward the
end of bavier's life griffith called her
and made amends as he recounted i hadn't
talked to her in a long time she said
i'm sorry we didn't get along better she
said it was my fault hopefully this
clearing of the air gave bavier some
degree of peace check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you